Pokemon go the real life augmented
reality phone game where you can catch
pokemon out in the wild is one step
closer to release I'm Kate and this is
your gamespot news update Pokemon fans
in Japan can now sign up for a Pokemon
go field test developer niantic has
announced this field test will start in
Japan later this month and will come to
other countries in the weeks to come
Pokemon go will let players catch train
and battle monsters in the real world
though niantic has yet to provide any
specifics on how this will work users
will be able to play the game with an
optional device called Pokemon go plus
much like a smart watch it can be worn
on the wrist and used to execute in-game
actions such as catching a Pokemon the
device will connect to smartphones using
bluetooth and will flash its LED and
vibrate to notify players about nearby
pokemon pokemon go is expected to be
available on the App Store and Google
Play in 2016 as a free download the game
will also have in-app purchases in other
news niantic recently canceled a Pokemon
go presentation at the game developers
conference are you excited for Pokemon
go let me know in the comments or come
and find me on Twitter I'm at how not to
draw thanks for watching and for all
your gaming and entertainment news keep
it gamespot